>> SOME DEMOCRATS ARE PREPARING
FOR A TRUMP IMPEACHMENT.
AND NOW, THE MAJORITY OF HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING THAT THEY.
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
LAYING OUT A POTENTIAL
TIMETABLE.
WATCH THIS.
>> IF WE DECIDE TO REPORT
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT, WE
COULD GET THAT IN THE LATTER
PART OF THE YEAR.
I THINK THAT WE COULD PROBABLY
GET COURT DECISIONS BY THE END
OF OCTOBER, MAYBE SHORTLY
THEREAFTER.
WE WILL HAVE HEARINGS IN
SEPTEMBER AND OCTOBER.
NOT TO DEPENDENT ON COURT
PROCEEDINGS.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE JERRY NADLER
HAS LAID OUT A TIMETABLE,
SOMETIME THIS FALL.
I'M REALLY SURPRISED THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE THAT LOW RIGHT NOW,
GIVEN ALL THE TALK ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL TRAIL.
BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THIS FALL, YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS AND
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
>> I SAY WHO CARES.
IT GOES NOWHERE.
I DON'T THINK IT MATTERS AT ALL.
GO AHEAD.
DO IT.
IT'S GOING TO HURT YOUR PARTY
AND HELP THE PRESIDENT.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
I MEAN, WHAT ARE YOU SO WORKED
UP ABOUT?
YOU FRAMED TRUMP, HE CAUGHT YOU.
NOW IT JUST LOOKS LIKE THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
WAS TO COVER UP THE FRAME JOB.
THERE WAS NO CRIME, AND
EVERYBODY CAN SEE THAT.
THE MUELLER STUNT FAILED.
NOW THEY ARE JUST FLAILING
AROUND, TRYING TO MAKE SOMETHING
ELSE WORK.
NOTHING HAS WORKED SO FAR.
THEY ARE GOING.
>> WHAT YOU THINK CUSTOMER >> I
THINK IT'S A BAD MOVE, BECAUSE
IF I WAS A DEMOCRAT, I WOULD NOT
DO THAT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT A LOT OF
MODERATE DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR
TRUMP THROUGHOUT THE MIDWEST.
THEY GOT THEIR JOBS BACK AND
THEY ARE MAKING MORE MONEY.
THEIR TAXES ARE LOWER.
THEY ARE GOING, WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT CONTINUE.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BACKFIRE
ON THEM.
>> IF THEY COME FORWARD AND
TESTIFY AND LOWER THE
TEMPERATURE AND GIVE THE
COMMITTEE WHAT THEY NEED THAT
THIS WILL GO AWAY?
>> Dana: I MEAN, GO AWAY, LIKE
IMPEACHMENT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
I HAVE HAD, WE'VE ALL HAD PEOPLE
WHISPERING IN OUR EAR THAT THE
EVIDENCE IS COMING.
THE EVIDENCE IS COMING.
WE ARE ALMOST ONE YEAR AWAY FROM
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE SO FAR.
THE REASON THESE NUMBERS ARE
GOING UP, HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE
WANTING TO TAKE BACK THE HOUSE.
THEY'VE GOT AN UPHILL CLIMB, BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY ARE DOING
IS THEY ARE TAKING THE 31
DISTRICTS WHERE TRUMP WON THE
HOUSE DISTRICT.
AND THEN THE DEMOCRATS WANTED IN
2018.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO PUSH
BACK SO THAT THEY CAN RUN
AGAINST THEM AND HOPEFULLY GET
THEIR SEATS BACK.
THAT'S THEIR PLAN.
THE THING THAT NANCY PELOSI IS
TRYING TO PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE.
>> GREG, EVERYTHING IS ON THE
SHOW, SHOULDERS OF BARREL HOW.
WILL BE GIVEN TO THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
>> Greg: THIS IS LIKE ME
WRITING A LOVE POEM AND SENDING
IT TO HALLE BERRY.
NOTHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S GOING NOWHERE.
>> Dana: , JOHN COULD TURN IT
INTO A SONG.
>> Greg: BUT DOESN'T REDUCE
THE TEMPERATURE OF THE COUNTRY,
HARDLY.
>> MY PROBLEM IS THAT MOST
PEOPLE THINK THAT IF WE IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP, WE WILL REMOVE HIM
FROM OFFICE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WON'T HAPPEN.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SHOULD CONDUCT AN
INQUIRY.
BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT WE NEED TO
FIND ANOTHER WAY TO GET RID OF
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT'S WHY